The American Medical Association has decided to officially classify obesity as a disease.
According to the Centers for Disease Control and Prevention over 1/3 of Americans are obese.
Although obesity is associated with a variety of different health problems like diabetes or heart condition,...
...until now it was not recognized as a disease, but rather a condition that caused other diseases.
The AMA's decision might influence both health care professionals and insurance providers...
...to start treating obesity in a different way,...
...which includes reimbursements for treatment of the disease.
One potential issue with the decision is that it will change the treatment from lifestyle choices...
...to a more clinical approach.
The AMA's decision addresses the myriad of issues surrounding obesity, saying,...
..."There are hormonal and metabolical abnormalities not reversible by lifestyle interventions..."
"...that will likely require multiple different risk stratified interventions for patients."